[Music]
Casey Martin was a professional golfer
with a bad leg due to a circulatory
disorder walking the course for 18 holes
of golf was painful for Martin it even
posed a serious risk that he might
fracture his leg
despite this disability he was an
excellent golfer he asked the pga the
Professional Golfers Association for
permission to use a golf cart during the
tournaments
the PGA said no Martin took his case to
court he invoked the law requiring that
organizations make reasonable
accommodations for people with
disabilities provided the accommodation
did not fundamentally alter the nature
of the activity many of the great
golfers of the past testified in court
that walking the course was an essential
part of the game the case went all the
way to the US Supreme Court the court
ruled in Martin's favor they said he did
have a right to use a golf cart in the
tournaments the court ruled that the
essence of golf was the ability to make
shots not the ability to walk the course
critics argued that giving Martin a
right to ride in a golf cart while
competing in professional tournaments
would be like giving a disabled
basketball player who was a great
shooter the right to play in the NBA
while riding up and down the court in a
motorized scooter what do you think do
you agree with the reasoning of the
court or with the reasoning of the
critics